thank you very much mr. president honor
remembers when we look at the beginning
of the century something was missing in
the European project
Biron Curtain had already fallen the
European communities were already a
well-established reality and yet they
lacked something in the words of my
predecessor Jacques of the law Europe
needed a soul Elodie setelem amando
Donna Nam Aloha and this is what Lisbon
is all about if you ask the lawyers they
will explain that the Lisbon Treaty has
given Europe a single legal personality
yet yes of course this was so but it is
more the Lisbon Treaty has given Europe
a soul or rather it has rediscovered
Europe's true soul the soul that made us
fight against tyranny and defeated the
soul that brought down the Iron Curtain
and reunited our continent the Lisbon
Treaty went to the core of the European
identity democracy the rule of law
rights and liberties for all and Lisbon
gave center stage to the citizens of
Europe it has brought more power to the
European Parliament the house of the
European democracy it has called
national parliaments to the forefront
and it has given to the European
citizens their right to call on the
Commission to propose legislation it was
a breath of fresh air that went through
the European democracy the European
project yes was built around the economy
but Europe was always meant to be more
than coal and steel more than a single
market it was always meant to be a union
and with Lisbon Europe rediscovered this
vocation shaddup you team don't see
these Danielle's on a divan low do table
on souffle Sumatran Yan may not renew at
tomorrow's Oh
cheaply Makena on Papa Lenovo defeat
Napa Valley spa Malad MOC Pascal
presuppose Dhoni passive any valor de
sea treaty a duper propia not Reno
Nevada fait accompli LAN construction
perpetual letter schwa a lovely chat
room ASAP celibate a Asus angular et
Ossa converter new novel passenger
utility tool a possibility to traité de
Lisboa Dupree dermal says Oh Tonka mini
salman de la défense recon tribal addict
Avila
constructed a promenade Oh Matilda
divorce settlement lexicon sub diamo
Union de la différence
elle était de ja donut reach a mess on
potential navigate a paddock over the
treaty ANCA beaucoup d'autre another
fear apocalypse wat alko please if
ACCA's 350 plus over N J alluvium at no
the metro nerve nerve totally potent
Lisbon in is a rotten debacle
proposition see Dom sets illusory yellow
new cinema she dared is Annie
no no regard to honor Martin overly
pushing diesel constricted new good
homes unfair it's also Kelly's seat wire
over PA good huntin fair O'Donnell is
born all said demo day on curve co-op
pavetta Bois I mean one drop o Okuda see
didn't have the need they merely on the
situation appear sunday sunday dollar
brown this song the trap will blue
weekly dues it while not a drop o area a
diamond of a pea sis or talk to
yes me only Cavalli note the Lina a
larva Lemuria not renew Laura Sassoon
say sit where no sape of koala
conference to lava near the LOB to
associate a oven to la confianza de veau
au todo SE kill new dota de nuevo
répondre à l'heure preoccupation yellow
roses pas sur le ebin american up over
100 treaty the lisbon treaty Kidani UNAM
a treaty key icky you know our situation
at reticulum illicit wherever they are
occur before a european no ups a luxury
c'est l'heure a veneer yellow opsin not
Joshua kanuda villanova lee sejoon
doloxan Villa Grazia